[Music]  folger's aroma roasted coffee made from  mountain grown beans richly roasted and  finely ground  for great waking up aroma  what are you doing hey  i'm drinking coffee uh-huh yeah i see  that  but you know i own a matcha spot  right yeah but i want coffee  yeah but matcha does the same [ __ ] it  has uh caffeine  antioxidants uh althea nine okay  what's healthier nine okay i don't care  i don't give a [ __ ]  i'll throw this cup away right now make  me a cup of my hey it don't matter we're  not friends drink whatever you want  ain't talking you no more  [ __ ] you too then drink more coffee i  wake up in the morning  shut up it's junebe in your cup and  that's not even folgers it's nestled you  idiot yeah if you don't drink my matcha  we ain't friends  still drinking coffee man [ __ ] you